[موسيقى]
دبلن رائعة ، لكن إذا رأيت
عاصمة أيرلندا فقط فأنا أحمق
وخدعت نفسي ،
فأنا أتخلى عن المنحدرات الدرامية
في الغرب وأتجه جنوبًا
بدلاً من ذلك إلى حيث يبدأ طريق الأطلسي البري في
الواقع
مكانًا يعتبر نفسه
العاصمة الحقيقية للجمهورية ،
تفتخر آلان بأطعمةها الطازجة
والسوق الإنجليزي الذي كان موجودًا هنا منذ عام
هو مركز طازج
[موسيقى]
، ستجد أن هناك القليل من كل
حيوان في هذا السوق
وأضمن لك الثراء إذا وقفت
لفترة كافية ، سيأخذ شخص ما
قضمًا هنا ، حسنًا باتريك
فيتزباتريك معي ، إنه
مؤلف الممثل الكوميدي وأهل الفلين وقد
اكتشف كيف يربحني ، هل
عليك تجربة أشياء مثل
شرائح الكسترد ،
أنا أحب شريحة الكاسترد
آيس كريم الكاسترد
في كعكة
[موسيقى]
شكرًا جزيلاً لك لقد
أتيت إلى هنا من أجل الطعام الطازج ،
فنوعية هذا
رائع ، ما زلت أتواصل بسبب الترحيب
الصباحي يا سيدي ، كيف حالك؟  أنت جيد ، كم من الوقت
يعمل هذا المفتاح إذا لم يكن لديك
في الثلاجة ، فأنت لا تريد أن يكون لديك
درجة حرارة الأشعة تحت الحمراء ، فعليك أن تمتلكه
في
ما هو مختلف عن الفلين مقارنة
بدبلن لدينا رأي أقل بكثير عن
أنفسنا ولكننا نتظاهر  خلاف ذلك ،
لدينا حول عقدة النقص
ومجمع التفوق في مدينة بارك
كورك الكلاسيكية الثانية ، حوالي
عُشر حجم الضوضاء السكانية
في دبلن
أم
أنها
ضغينة أنها تحتوي على شريحة على كلا
الكتفين ولديها فكرة
أنها أيرلندا الحقيقية
لذلك وأعتقد أن هناك القليل من الحقيقة في
ذلك لدرجة أنه إذا ذهبت إلى
دبلن الآن ، يمكن أن تشعر وكأنها لندن أم صغيرة في
حين أن هذا يبدو وكأنه مدينة كبيرة
وبلدة إيرلندية كبيرة ،
فإن السوق الإنجليزي كان مجرد
طبق رئيسي  تقع على بعد 20 دقيقة من
الطريق
وقلعة بلارني وحجرها الشهير
الذي تقول الأسطورة إنه يمنح هدية
الثرثرة لمن يقبلونها ،
لذا فالسؤال هو هل ستقبل
الحجر الدموي الذي لم يكن لدي قط ،
فأنا لست في الخامسة والخمسين من العمر  أنا ني  لقد نشأت وترعرعت على
بعد 10 كيلومترات
جيدًا لأنه شيء سياحي في
حال لاحظت أننا سائحون
جزء مني يعتقد أن 40.000 شخص
قد قبلوها في الـ 48 ساعة الماضية
ماذا تعرف عنهم تعرف  لا
أمانع في تقبيل الناس ، لكنني على الأقل أحب
مقابلتهم أولاً ، ربما أشتري مشروبًا
لجهلي ، كنت أعتقد دائمًا أن
حجر بلارني كان صخرة على جرف
يطل على المحيط ،
إنه ليس
صخرة في الجدار في الأعلى  من
القلعة ،
انظر إلى ذلك ، حسنًا ، أنا أقبل ،
أعتقد أنني أقبل ،
حسنًا ، لقد خرجت لتترك
انطباعًا ، أليس
كذلك ، كيف حالك مع المرتفعات ،
أنا بخير في ذلك
[موسيقى
] آمل أن تكون على دراية بأن المشي إلى الجزء
العلوي من القلعة شاق ، ولا
أعلم أن أحدًا منا لن يفعل ذلك
، لم يكن مخطئًا
شاقًا بالفعل مع لحظات مثيرة
على طول طريقة
مشاهدة المناظر الرائعة  هذا
يا إلهي ، إنه مستقيم ، أليس كذلك
إنه تقريبًا أوه ، لا توجد خطوات أخرى ،
حسنًا ، لقد كنت أتمنى أن يكون هناك "  يكون هناك المزيد من
السلالم ، شخص ما مات وهو يفعل هذا
قبل الآن ، أخبرنا لا قبل أن
يضعوا الدرابزين في هذه الفكرة المبهجة ،
أليس كذلك
أنت لا تتجعد وتتكئ على أوه ،
لا
تقبيل حجر بلارني هو عمل
في حد ذاته
حسنًا ، هذا حجر حسنًا ، ها نحن ذا ،
وقد وصلوا إلى فن جميل مع
الكثير من المساعدة في طريق العودة ،
أمسك القضبان خلفك ،
ثني رأسك لأسفل ،
شاهد رأسك الآن هنا ،
أوه لن ينجح إذا لم تفعل ذلك  تقبيل
اللمعان ،
هل تفتح عينيك أم
تغمض عينيك في حالتك ،
سواء كنت تستخدم اللسان أم لا ، فهذا
هو ما فعلته لأنني أريد أن أعرف
لأنني أنا التالي ،
كم عدد الأشخاص اليوم 550 شخصًا قبلات
550  الناس في
الواقع مقدار المطهر على
هذا الحجر الذي تم مسحه بعد كل قبلة
لن يجرؤ أي فيروس على الاقتراب
منه وكان هناك الكثير من المرح ،
لقد حصلت على هدية الكابينة الآن
يمكنني التحدث عن طريقي للانحناء أعتقد أنه
هناك  طريقة أخرى للخروج من هنا لأنني
لا أريد كل شيء إلى الأبد
نحن  لقد فعلنا ذلك ، لقد قبلنا الحجر الشقراء
والآن انظروا إلى ما حدث جيدًا
في المرة القادمة سندفع جيدًا
وسندفع ثمن طريقنا